what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable
future oh man I got to tell you guys um
I was going through the Titans annual
and technically I'm kind of jumping the
gun here a bit just because of the fact
that there is still like there's there's
Maiden Manhattan and that kind of thing
but for those of you guys who don't know
usually when it comes around to the
point you know usually when we hit the
one year mark and we start cranking out
annuals what'll happen is a Publishers
will say like if we have 12 months
before an annual hits or 11 months or 13
or however it is they choose to do it
and we have like a six issue story arc
and a five isue story arc well that
gives us 11 issues so they say we have
one more before we do an annual they
just usually do like a one shot or
something like that something to just
kind of fill the gaps to keep the
publication going until we can get an
annual and then a new story arc will
start up but what this does this
actually is this is a huge moment in in
the story or I guess in the history of
Donna Troy's character and the reason
why is because her publication history
is a nightmare we'll get to that here in
a second
it's crazy her publication history like
her her origin all that kind of stuff
but what this does is this initially
picks up with G or Aqualad depending on
what you want to call them alongside
like Wally West and Barry Allen just
appearing in a singular location not
only that we also get Aquaman Arthur
Curry and so what we basically have here
are mentors and proteges that's really
what this is mentors and proteges now
this is cool because this is what the
Titans are founded on keep in mind
before they were Titans they were Teen
Titans and originally the Teen Titans
were basically just the sidekicks of
DC's main line of superheroes that's one
of the reasons why fans loved the Teen
Titans so much is because well if they
couldn't be Aquaman you know they could
be the next best thing which was
basically Aquaman's Mentor it was like
you know DC publishing a lot of
superheroes aimed explicitly for kids
and the story the story sold well there
was one point where the Teen Titans were
the highest selling team in comic books
and I mean taking everybody into account
Marvel's X-Men Marvel's Avengers DC's
Justice League Batman the whole n yards
the Teen Titans were the highest selling
comic book book at the time because it
was a comic book aimed at teenagers
dealing with teenage issues gaining love
losing love learning how to find their
place in the world I mean just different
things like that these existential
crises that teenagers go through who am
I where am I going what's my future like
where did I come from all these
different things that kind of come
together to make us who we are and send
us in you know forward into the world
but we also have is Dick Grayson
arriving on the scene and so pretty
quickly we really get this understanding
you know at least from the way Dan Abnet
is writing it that we're basically going
to be seeing a lot of these characters
coming together now of course the
immediate question here is what's going
on but there's also a bit of rivalry
keep in mind that with the Titans they
looked up to the Justice League at one
point as mentors and they still do to a
degree but they've also stepped into
their own you know the Titans are really
kind of their own who their own
superhero now they're their own Heroes
we've basically grown up and that's what
makes this cool is because it's almost
like an adult person challenging their
parent 25-year-old guy challenging his
40-year-old dad you know I'm 25 I'm an
adult you can't tell me what to do
anymore that's basically what this is
and this comes to fruition when Aquaman
immediately takes control and says you
got guys do this you guys do that well
of course you know Aqualad his immediate
response is who put you in charge now
the cool thing about this is Dan Abnet
also pay special attention to the legacy
of Dick Grayson and this is why people
love Dick Grayson so much is because
he's like the bright shining star in the
DC Universe right like everybody know
when when Dick Grayson speaks everybody
listens they may not necessarily agree
with him but they will all listen the
arguments will stop the discussions will
cease Dick Grayson will say his piece
and then the things will continue on in
whatever Direction they end up going in
maybe they'll follow di Grayson maybe
they won't but of course Di 's advice is
hey look Wally West The Flash Wally West
Berry Allen you're the two fastest
people here Scout the area out see what
you can see well almost immediately
after they take out they come across
Donna Troy and Wonder Woman now right
off the bat the two of them are at odds
with one another I mean Wonder Woman
does not trust Donna Troy now on the
surface this seems to be indicated by
the fact that Wonder Woman is basically
saying you know I don't know who you are
I don't know if I can trust you I
suddenly just appear in this strange
location but then suddenly I see you now
what dad abet seems to be doing is kind
of feeding on the Wonder Woman origin of
Donna Troy and what I mean by that is
Donna Troy has been God Donna Troy has
been a
nightmare for DC Comics ever since her
Inception I have a video where I talk
about that but we won't we won't go
super in depth but the idea here is that
originally Wonder Girl was just like
Wonder Woman's super boy that's what it
was super boy told the stories of
Superman when he was a kid Wonder Girl
told the stories of Wonder Woman when
she was a little girl the problem with
this was that Wonder Girl was just
rolled over into the Teen Titans
Publications one day and so what we got
was presumably Wonder Woman as a little
girl in the modern day well then this
raised continuity issues you know how
can Wonder Girl be Wonder Woman as a
child in the modern day if time travel
or nothing like that is invoked and so
what ended up happening is DC basically
reworked the origin of Wonder Girl and
that's what been happening time and time
again her origin has just constantly
been reworked and in fact you had
characters like Cassie sandsmark that
would pop up and undertake the mantle of
Wonder Girl but with regards to Donna
Troy her origin has changed consistently
over the years because of the fact that
no one seems to be able to settle on
what her origin needs to be now more
recently the origin of Donna Troy fell
into the idea that she was basically
created to kill off Wonder Woman and
take her place as Queen of the mcira now
Titans hunt came back and changed that a
little bit the reason why I say that is
because of the fact that when the new 52
was launched there was no Titans and
that was a whole issue Teen Titans was
the original publication Titans was spun
off that saw the original Teen Titans
forming their own team and then that
iteration of the Teen Titans became a
different team and so you had the two of
them running in tandem you had the
original Team Titans who were now the
Titans you had the new Team Titans which
were a different group of people now
when the new 52 started you had a
rebooted Teen Titans but the Titans
didn't exist there was no Donna Troy
there was none of that stuff was there
there was no Wally West or at least the
Wally West as we knew him that wasn't
there and so fans were kind of outraged
fans were kind of mad we got Titans hunt
which basically went back and said okay
Donna Troy was part of the original Teen
Titans but the issue with this is that
the origin with donat Troy being part of
the Teen Titans and the origin of donat
Troy in the Wonder Woman Comics
contradicted one another and so it
created it created even more anity
issues that made things wildly difficult
now that being said the purpose of
rebirth is in a lot of ways to wipe the
Slate clean with different characters
Donna Troy being a perfect example we'll
get to that here in a minute but in the
midst of these whole discussions again
it creates some some bumping of heads
between these two different you know
these two different groups because you
got the Titans who are like we're grown
up we're heroes we know what we're doing
and the Justice League who are like
we're The Originals or at least what
passes for the Justice League here Barry
Allen uh Aquaman and and really Batman
that's really about it in ter I guess
the Wonder Woman that's really it in
terms of like the Justice League but
they're like look we're The Originals
you were mentored based off us we still
know what's best now this is really DC
sitting down and saying hey look guys
the Titans are their own superhero Team
all right the Titans are not the
proteges the Titans are their own Heroes
now they're not Sidekicks anymore they
are now grown up they're their Heroes
they're out in the world they're driving
they're complaining about paying bills
and they're paying rent in a place is
just too damn expensive the rent is too
damn high they are they are their own
superheroes now now the reason why this
matters is because if you're a Titans
fan this is what you've been waiting for
I mean unofficially it's been stated for
like years and years and years
unofficially you've known that but
there's a difference between knowing it
and believing it's true and DC saying it
is true you know this is how it is and
so I feel like for Titans fans this is
Vindication I mean they can help but
feel a little bit heartened over the
idea that like finally man like people
are taking the Titan seriously I mean
it's it's one of those things where it's
just kind of something people have been
waiting for now of course what we also
get is the return of a villain named key
who's basically The Mastermind behind
all this now with this guy the key being
introduced into this story DC's reaching
back man they're reaching back to
All-Star comics in 1951 I think I think
it's Allstar Comics but they're reaching
back to like the 1950s the key was
really like this low-level villain but
he's a guy who's like a master chemist
he's really good with like developing
components and you know machinery and
different things like that but we don't
know why he's doing this all we know is
that there is a door somewhere that
needs to be unlocked that somebody is
behind now who this person is we don't
know now my idea here is it's probably
not somebody like Dr Manhattan it's
probably not even somebody like blank or
blanch or whatever you want to call it
from the Superman comics it's probably
just some villain that we've seen before
who's coming back or some villain that
we've never seen before we don't really
know who it is now I'm intrigued I'm
interested to find out who it is but we
don't know who that guy is but what we
do know is that in order for this person
to be released in order for enough
energy to be built up that this door can
be opened the various Heroes have to
fight one another and so because of this
what ends up happening here is it
basically allows you know the members of
the Justice League and the Titans to
come together but for Batman to also
take control now that's the funny thing
about this is because when Batman steps
in he was like okay here's what we're
doing the discussion is now over your
arguments are now done everybody is
going to do what I tell them to and we
expect that right I mean Dan Abnet plays
it fast and loose because we expect him
to when Dad Ander comes along and he was
like Hey guys Batman's here then it's
like okay well I guess Batman's running
the show now and even then like Barry
and Barry Allen and Wally West comment
on that Barry's like hey look when
Batman comes into the room the
discussion is over man it's it's always
been that way but it also makes sense
because he's the smartest out of all of
them so it makes sense if you were going
to have somebody come in and say okay I
am now in control it would be Batman and
so because of this we kind of get this
continued riff between Wonder Woman and
Donna Troy but we also end up seeing the
intelligence and the detective work of
Dick Grayson and the reason why is
because he says look we've been brought
here deliberately he says we've been
brought here for the sole purpose of
fighting the reason he knows that is
because Wonder Woman's lasso of Truth is
gone and no one noticed that until Dick
Grayson said it and that's one of the
cool things that's that's why I like his
character is because in this story
everybody gets their own little moment
the Great of or I guess the aspect of
each of these individual Heroes that
makes them great gets highlighted and so
that's one of the cool things about
annuals is because annuals are basically
one shots they're one-offs you don't
really have I mean you you can to a
degree they'll start a story but it's
not usually like you have a story called
you know the Rob cor is the most amazing
group ever and it starts with annual
number one and then goes into 1 2 3 4 5
and six usually annuals are either a
Prelude or they're a one shot but again
we also get this this really cool scene
where they're basically trying to break
out they're trying to figure out what's
going on but what the key basically does
while he he's observing this and says
look in order for this door to be opened
they have to be fighting and so what we
need is for them to face off against a
common enemy and this is when the keys
abilities as a not really an inventor so
much as a replicator begin to come into
play when he basically brings in Metallo
he also starts bringing in parademons
different things like that and they all
start facing off against I mean the the
the Justice League and the Teen Titans
are able to work together well enough
they can they can face off against them
all and there's really not a whole lot
you know of exposition here they're
really able to to kind of save the day
but what we also end up finding out here
is that these different rooms you know
as they've been constructed as Wally
West and Barry Allen have explored them
have been designed in such a way that
they're they're basically made to
neutralize the powers of people meaning
they're allowed to use their abilities
but their abilities can't necessarily
override the function of the room as an
example there's telepathic blocking and
so the other Justice League members
especially someone like Omen can't use
her telepathy to find out where they are
the walls have been constructed in such
a way that the flash they can't simply
vibrate through them and the entire
structure is super strong so you know
Wonder Woman and Aquaman can't punch
through it and and so it's really just
the circumstance where they have to work
together and put their brains to task
and use each other's abilities in order
to get themselves out now at this point
the cool thing is that it's really just
a matter of kind of exploring the area
facing off against these different
forces but the funny thing is that it's
also Batman's moment and this is
actually really small here but it's one
of the things that I that I really dig
about this Dan Abnet is kind of
interesting when it comes to writing
Comics because he's hit and miss but in
this one he's really really really good
and the reason why I say that is because
we get this natural kind of paranoia
based on how things currently exist as
well as Batman being intelligent what I
mean by that is with regards to DC
following the reboot of the new 52 in
2011 with Titans rebirth this is the
first time we see the Reformation of the
Titans team this is the first time
they've actually operated together as a
team not only that the pre flash point
Wally West is just suddenly here no one
really trusts him it's just him showing
up making claims about some guy you know
who has the has the ability to wipe 10
years from everybody's memories and
stuff like that and basically just kind
of mess around with the timeline what he
can't prove it all he could could do a
show up to Batman point at a button and
say see that's an indication even
Batman's a little skeptical about it but
no one really can take or they can look
at evidence to verify Wally West claims
because of this because of the fact that
the Titans are like look we're a
close-knit group it puts them at odds
with the Justice League and the reason
why is because of the fact that the
Titan entire concept is built on trust
as far as Dick Grayson knows as far as
Wally West knows Donna Troy they've been
a team they they remember each other
they they've been an intricate part of
each other's lives but they can't prove
this to the Justice League the Justice
League just has to kind of take their
word for it but from The Stance of the
Justice League suddenly we have you know
Dick Grayson saying hey look you know we
as the Titans have been together you
know we've we've been a team for quite
some time Donna Troy comes along yeah
you know we've been a team the pre-
flash point Wally West just seemingly
pops out of nowhere and says yeah I was
part of this team and so because the
Justice League doesn't really know if
they can trust them and so you guys are
kind of seeing how they're bumping heads
how this issue of trust is really kind
of coming to a head with regards to how
the how each team views the other but
then we have Batman behind the scenes
kind of standing in the background
investig ating things taking one of the
goggles off these parad demons and
saying hey look these things are
designed to sense organic material to
sense you know basically biological
signals and is Batman just doing his
detective work and that's what's cool is
because while everybody's arguing
Batman's solving the problem and that's
the nature of his character even if
Batman is in the middle of fighting just
like everybody else he's doing multiple
things at once he's figuring a solution
to the problem this is just a
circumstance where he's just not
partaking in all the bickering that's
going on but what he does is he
basically uses the goggles of the
parademon and more or less creates a
scanner I mean us it you know it's
Batman tools whatever Batman could do
anything he wants to at any particular
point in time Batman fans will tell you
that but Batman basically just kind of
like rigs up a scanner and then starts
going through and analyzing people and
saying there's only there's eight people
here but there's only seven organic
signatures the one person who's not
organic is Donna Troy now this is where
this kind of retcon seems to come into
play now I'll be honest here as
tight-knit as DC rebirth is in terms of
how the stories are being published the
significance of continuity I mean DC is
really going like the Valiant comics
route with continuity like we're playing
it close to the vest like everything is
in continuity everything is tight-knit
it has to be this is Classic this is is
a Hallmark of Jeff John's in terms of
his writing style this seems to be DC
going with the origin story that Donna
Troy is not human she's not organic
she's not a normal human being she
thinks she is but she's not now they're
also kind of delving into this bit of a
Wonder Woman origin and essentially
saying that donat Choy was created for
the purpose of usurping Wonder Woman of
basically taking her out of killing her
and taking her place the efforts of
Donna Troy were defeated and then she
was given false memories and allowed to
go forward as a normal human being now
the reason why this is significant is
because what this does is it brings the
world of donat try crashing down around
her but it also sets the stage for DC to
come along and say now here is a four or
five or you know three or six issue
miniseries on the origin of Donna Troy
here is the tried and true origin of her
character for the future until
presumably in some five or six or seven
years when somebody changes something or
something like that but it basically
sets the stage for DC to give Donna Troy
presumably her own miniseries that
explores all these different things
explores these aspects or maybe even
just roll them over into the Titans book
and bolster the team's connection to one
another by going on this sort of Journey
where they figure out what donat Troy's
life is really all about now what Wonder
Woman also says is she held these things
close she didn't reveal this to donat
try because she didn't want to destroy
her world but because of everything
that's going on Wonder Woman offers this
explanation and again it brings Donna
Troy's World crashing down around her
now because of the emotional Outburst
that comes from this because of the fact
that Donna Troy feels such a significant
loss and such a significant level of
confusion while her friends race to
comfort her two things happen the first
is that this emotional Outburst this
energy that's being released allows for
this you know really for for key to kind
of push things a bit further in order to
allow that door to be unlocked but it
also allows Lilith it allows Omen to
telepathically get a brief connection to
Donna Troy it's not huge it's not major
it doesn't reestablish things but it's
almost like shooting up a flare and so
because of this omen now knows exactly
where Donna Troy and the other members
of the Justice League and the Titans are
located and so what this does is it
wraps up pretty fast and that's kind of
the cool thing about this is that it all
wraps up pretty quick because this isn't
designed this annual is not designed to
answer all the questions it's designed
to give us more questions it's designed
to give us a reason to continue reading
the the Titans comic and that's what I
like about this is because it gives us
just enough to give us a story but it
also lays the groundwork for the future
of what we can expect to see in the
Titans Publications and so using a
scanner B Batman basically figures out
where it is that key located they race
off to him Batman I'm sorry Superman and
Lilith and and Cyborg and the Green
Lanterns and Arsenal they all show up
and they basically all just kind of you
know get ready to challenge key and then
key just basically bails out he just
takes off and so back at the Titans
Tower is basically again the stage being
set for you know Donna Troy to kind of
go on this soul searching quest to
figure out what she's about or or
whatever the case may be but it's also
this idea that whoever this being is
that was behind this door has
essentially killed a key or at least
presumably has killed a key now again we
don't know who this guy is we don't know
what he's about we don't even know if
it's a guy it could be a woman it could
just be some weird alien thing we have
no clue what's going on here but what it
does do is kind of egas on of it and it
says hey look if you guys want to know
what happens next you know continue
reading the Titans book but again I just
want to kind of bring this to you guys
cuz I thought it was a really great
exploration into how the Titans and the
Justice League view one another as well
as the fact that we get this pretty huge
Revelation with uh with Donna Troy but
if you guys are new here to Comics
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the robore if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]
[Applause]